2000 enfants fréquentent cette école
en apparence tout va bien mais
l'établissement est menacée de
démolition car le propriétaire du
terrain une société municipale a
subitement décidé de le récupérer
même si le bail est encore bon le
problème c'est qu'il s'agit d'une des
écoles autofinancé vers lesquels se
tourner du million d'élèves qui ont
difficilement accès aux services publics
dans des grandes villes comme pékin
tout simplement parce qu'ils sont les
enfants de travailleurs migrants et
chinois venus des provinces et leur
permis de résidence le rocco est limité
à leur lieu d'origine
là où ils doivent en principe aller à
l'école ou se faire soigner parmi les
parents inquiets
cette mère se demande quel avenir aura
mon fils s'il doit retourner à la
campagne tél combien craint de devoir
partir seul à 14 ans dans l'est du pays
et d'être livrée à elle-même comme de
nombreux enfants qui n'ont pu suivre
leurs parents migrants
les responsables de l'école tente
d'apaiser les craintes
il parle d'un sursis jusqu'au printemps
mais ce professeur pense que les
bulldozer pour s pointer à nouveau après
une tentative avortée l'été dernier
ils sont déjà à l'oeuvre ailleurs dans
la capitale dans des quartiers de
migrants il ya quelques semaines à peine
sa bourdonnais d'activités commerciales
d'activité résidentiel aujourd'hui ce
n'est que gravats et recyclage et
amertume chez ceux qui plie bagage
des dizaines de personnes vivaient et
travaillaient dans cette petite usine de
vêtements qui traînent affirment qu'ils
n'ont eu que quelques jours d'avis avant
d'être contraint à partir on nous a
coupé l'électricité et l'eau dit il
officiellement les autorités évoquent
des raisons de sécurité de salubrité le
mois dernier l'incendié d'un de ces
édifices de fortune où vivent souvent
les chinois venus des provinces avaient
fait une vingtaine de morts
les migrants y voit un prétexte pour se
débarrasser d'eux pour embellir la
capitale
ils sont quelques 8 millions à pékin
soit le tiers des résidents la ville
peinent à absorber autant de monde
embouteillage pollution pression sur les
ressources
cette analyse de précise que la
municipalité et soucieuses d'attirer des
emplois en finance ou en informatique
tout en voulant maintenir sa population
sous la barre des 23 millions donc elles
délocalisent des secteurs qui ne sont
plus jugées essentielles son statut de
capitale soit tout le tournoi future
retraite
pourquoi en chine des secteurs comme le
petit commerce les usines ou les
livraisons ou travaillent beaucoup de
migrants une main d'oeuvre bon marché
yang traîne envoyait une bonne partie de
son salaire à sa famille à son fils
resté dans le sichuan
il ne sait pas ce qui l'attend les
jeunes troyens ninive alors je suis
écoeuré dit il quand on est arrivé ici
l'endroit était pauvre il n'y avait même
pas de route
maintenant que la ville est prospère on
nous expulse lance-t-il avant d'ajouter
le pouvoir nous considère comme des
citoyens de seconde zone et encore à 1,3
d'initiés libéraux radio-canada pékin